Ibrahim Mansour was among 20 people
rescued in lebanon's worst migrant boat
tragedy in years
he reached the coast of Syria on
Thursday night he says he can't forgive
himself for not saving others
I cry all the time I'm in shock I saw
bodies in horrible images my heart hurts
I tried to help children and another man
Abed I tried to keep their Spirits alive
but I couldn't this is hurting me
especially because of the child who was
holding on to me before I lost him they
told me he died
dozens of Palestinian refugees were on
the boat attempting to reach Italy like
others it is poverty that pushed Ibrahim
to risk his life misery is everywhere in
lebanon's Palestinian camps
tells us how he now collects scrap and
plastic to feed his children
he is a University graduate but
authorities here deny this community
basic rights and bars members from many
professions so as not to encourage them
to stay
their dire situation was made worse by
lebanon's economic collapse that began
three years ago
many of the families are still waiting
for the bodies of their relatives some
have been identified and brought back
for burial others are still in Syria
awaiting the results of DNA tests until
they're received it won't be known how
many and who remain missing at sea
survivors and bodies of Lebanese and
Palestinian refugees are arriving home
but Syrian refugees who were among the
passengers have not returned neither
have their bodies
their families who escaped the rule of
President Bashar al-assad will be afraid
to cross the border to identify their
loved ones
[Music]
concerning the syrians on the part no
one on this side of the board I came to
us to ask for help to find missing
syrians
the Red Cross has been taking names of
those missing but there's only so much
it can do officials here tell us their
faith is in the hands of security
agencies and it's not clear if the
Syrian Nationals who survived will
return but those who have blame The
Smuggler for leaving them to die at sea
when the engine of the boat stopped we
called Abu Ali The Smuggler he told us
there will be a boat to get us in five
minutes we also called 112 to seek help
from Lebanese authorities but Noble came
on as more details of what happened
emerge International organizations say
conditions for forcibly displaced people
and hosted communities must improve and
while lebanon's instability and
financial meltdown continue to push
people to the brink this can't come soon
enough
Northern Lebanon